hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to soma so we just made
it to the living quarters and I don't
know why I'm here what's going well I
give me a second I'm doing my intro why
you gotta be all up in my grill why I
gotta back off my business why can't you
just leave me be
i'ma be me you be be you whoever you are
why am I in here I'm not doing any of
this see the thing is that don't exactly
know who you are if you're working for
we have to leave what why do we have to
leave I need to explore don't boss me
alone for that little there's something
here oh wow what the hell oh oh oh oh
oh that is bizarre
anyway you weird voice in my head you
don't get to dictate my actions I mean
eventually you might but for now well
well in no way he didn't tell me the war
was about that can we do anything for
him no we're out of sedatives if we had
a gun this would be the time to pull it
out did not expect you to end like this
should have jumped the Clara back to
Omicron without the ark forget about the
Ark no you don't get to say that it's
the only thing left of value you know
that yeah yeah promise you won't leave
it behind it well I'll be dead one day
then what well better keep it safe until
then don't want a while to take it
swallow it whole I'm sorry Catherine
it's okay and just let it out let it all
out okay alright then so I'm guessing
this must have been the conversation
that this guy heard as he was dying
which isn't necessarily a good thing is
this the way it rolls at the bottom of
the ocean
I remember them singing about that in
Little Mermaid but there it is
oh one the world oh oh man it's so Oh
what the [ __ ] did we do hey try not to
think about it my whole life I've been a
good man we messed up Sarah very there
should have launched taking the chance
there's time if Ashton says we could try
again when things calm down you got to
do it you know you got to
that's Catherine why does he have a
picture of Catherine May this is all
gonna get - another dilemma towards the
end of it if we actually ever do get on
the ark it's gonna be another situation
where it's just another copy made and
then one gets to be on the ark the other
does not
okay so that leasts the infirmary not
time yet boys in the head not time yet
dive room okay
I'm just trying to figure out my
bearings it's shove my hand in here I
know it won't stop just let me have this
moment trying to enjoy myself wish to
call lifts
Kabang okay well that doesn't work
anymore I don't even know if it worked
in the first place
why would I have tried to do it okay so
we got a few options here
and I really do wonder what the timeline
is between everything that happened
before and everything that's happening
now Oh anybody home
Upsilon I doubt anyone's gonna answer
hey I'm gonna fast-forward through this
a little bit and then figure out later
okay here we go all right we I I tried
all of them it didn't seem like anyone
was actually gonna go there Fuu
infirmary unlocked cabin a whoa what was
that
thank you thank you for that you fix it
for me good I'm glad that that happened
hello let's see urgent fix needed Tao
can retrieve the climber until the link
is working visited by sse volchok doll
in Hollands two bi-weekly visits
evacuation swarmed my monsters and no
radio okay good good to know what that
means that there should be this should
be open now okay
pink and this guy said there was nothing
here there's tons of stuff here there's
everything to be explored I don't know
any of this I can't read this hello what
is this alrighty then
so something's supposed it's ours was it
ain't some gel is what I'm assuming is
supposed to happen here and that'll kill
the whoa I was hoping to see Omicron
today vacua shun ordered by theta was a
gift excuse to leave alpha and abandon
the whoa all right so the whoa is down
here unless it's in this alpha
I'm talking about the ark postpone the
Ark launch turn fly someone how to
figure this Ark business out okay so
apparently not many people knew about
what was going on
the patent has stopped evolving the Wow
has managed to find balance I convinced
SSE volchek to turn off all external
control systems making a while our
de-facto caretaker so far it's exceeding
expectations yeah I'm sure it is common
crashing a few days ago January 12 the
Wow has dropped to a lower energy state
it hasn't abandoned its duties it's
keeping climate and life-support going
but it's been simplifying the path
redefining its protocol
the Wow has started to grow physically
it's not just the core chamber all
around pathos to structure gel is
bursting through the pipes and bleeding
through walls I don't know what Wow
could possibly stand to gain from this
but I assume it is intentional the heart
of WoW has claimed such a large part of
the core chamber that there can no
longer be any question - its heightened
awareness not only does its expansion
suggest an unexpected understanding of
space but also its own physical
manifestation within the world the Wow
is reaching out to every machine every
life-form to manipulate to control its
trying to help save its creators from
all this just like the protocol demands
but really what is good enough where is
the line drawn for what is human and
what is not wood walking corpses do
with a group of machines thinking their
human be acceptable
we can't trust a machine to know to
understand what it means to be we have
to terminate the wild project it can be
done I just need to get some help from
Omicron and best record that in a
electronic device so no possible machine
could look into it okay here we go whoa
it looks like an eyeball weird Oh grow e
Oh lovely Wow looking good oh my okay so
it's evolving which is a really
interesting concept hey those are the
things that I keep shoving my hand into
why does this tell me anything about it
apparently not okay well that was a fun
adventure I got some more of the story
which is nice oh oh I thought that was
something happening there never mind I'm
just being stupid okay so now I'm gonna
go on my way I think I need to go I'm
pretty sure down is usually where it
wants me to go but there's also here to
the infirmary which could lead to some
interesting discoveries not that I
imagine there's a way out of them for me
I mean I can always go back and consult
the map if I ever feel like I'm lost
again
hi you you're different are you
Catherine I'm me are you human
saralyn wall Oh payload technician at
your service
a rare sight all right I'd say so you're
the first normal living human I've seen
there's not many left down here most of
them are up on the plateau you mean at
Omicron yeah there's no one alive at
Omicron you've been there I've been all
over the power plant it Upsilon the
ruins of lambda the abandoned Delta
Theta I've been to theta
there's not a lot left of pathos to and
I'm the only living person you've met
you mean on the last living human on the
planet I'm sorry who are you again
Simon jarred station down nowhere
I used to work in a bookshop in Toronto
long story then what the hell are you
doing here we're trying to find the Ark
why would you how do you know about that
I've heard it's the last hope for
mankind damn right it is now what do you
want with it take it to the gonna file
aunch it into space how it was the plan
all right
I've been gardening ever since we
brought it back to Tao just bring myself
to let go hey Richard I don't have the
strength to argue
and I certainly don't have the time to
wait for the next sentient thing
shuffling through here go ahead take
thank you get you anything do anything
for you
you could kill me
oh man I'm glad you came by good to get
this over with
oh man you're leaving this up to me ah
you serious about me killing you know I
love to hang around here until I dry up
to the size of a raisin Simon this
[ __ ] sucks I don't want to live like
this
shouldn't we be doing something to keep
you alive why you're the last human it
just find it disrespectful to our entire
history not to fight this you're sure we
have the art but you're the real deal
Thanks that's probably the best
compliment I've ever got but the truth
is that the arc is all we have
we'll have to accept second best you
know
dan I think this feels right son I want
did
think about it dang man that's heavy
subjects be my guest
I got no secrets worth keeping I still
can't believe I'm the last one it's
crazy
hey this is like man hello who are you
Mansa photos of the entire who is that
supposed to be no idea
compound could keep you alive in
emergency situations how to keep
unconscious or comatose leakin oh man
dang oh alright then knock it out of the
park alright then
oh man in this situation I feel like I
know it's right may not seem right but
yep would you stay please
sure it won't be long now just please
just stay no problem oh man this is some
really heavy stuff crazy
this one's life
Leeson won't have to turn 30
we should go to died at home friends
you ever been to Greenland it's very
beautiful
or at least when you get out of the city
the knock is busy and yes there's like
12 million people trying to get around
it's a great place rather it was a great
place for the comment in digital
you know what
I prefer this way
I liked papers
like to my colleagues and Nick Jasper
even Catholic
people thought she was weird and she was
quiet she was cool
Simon you're still there I'm here sir
don't let him die okay
send them out there
oh man
black box is inactive probably found a
way to switch it off oh dang that is
absurdly heavy stuff oh man I don't
really have a lot of words to say about
if you're hoping for some wisdom from me
like you're not gonna get it
cuz I guess I could late in the bed this
must be weird hey how's it goin your
last moments this robot laying down in
the bed like this yeah but I mean if
you're looking for like some wisdom from
me about why what the choices that I
make are very reflective of the person I
am I suppose but it's also important for
me that you know things change from
situation to situation like it's I don't
know it's hard to explain it's not
something that I could easily know wit
let you guys know I'm carrying the ark
like this well what am I supposed to Oh
compact Freight lift oh that would be
the thing so you know what I mean like
it's
I don't know every choice that I make
varies from case an occasion that
doesn't mean that I flip-flop on my
opinion it's just that I apply my morals
to a very specific situation as each
time comes up so if that makes any sense
send that down to the diver I'm pretty
sure that's where I need to go goodbye
Sara I only spent 312 days while that
Ark was running so the people in the Ark
must be having a grand old time I'm
actually curious if the people in the
ark would have any idea what you know
it's like going on outside if there's
even a problem how would they know how
could they know oh man that is
mmm okay now we're back into the thick
of it things were well the one I'm not
too happy with me all right
the whoa would not do a B it is curious
like what is the end goal for a lot of
things here like what is the end
objective really and how did that lady
survive that long in there cuz
apparently I would imagine she survived
somewhere in the orders
about 300 days
um try put this back should I send this
up oh come on I was right here I was
right on top of the play I was just
trying to save the ark I mean water a
little water splish Splash I did not do
so good come on bring it back down now I
gotta wait okay
something doesn't seem too good over
here place cargo here how very obvious
all right swipe it nice whoa how about
you oh okay
what I need a better chip or something
let's config
apparently Katherine Chun was here okay
so I don't have a configuration so how
do I get a configuration file oh there
we go oh okay no the arc the water will
be damaged
Hey
what am I supposed to do about that
oh hey whoa I don't know I'm not I'm not
entirely sure that's what I'm whatever
it was all bunk anyway might as well
just break the [ __ ] um
oh there's another one here okay I can
see that one talking about hanging on by
a thread well I guess I'm dead now oh
boy
back in vbus good thing that things
meant to be sturdy
oh thank I have to admit that's not
entirely everything that I was expecting
okay excuse me let me get through first
OOP no almost oh no about to be crushed
hey wait a minute
hey whoa hey think you're going hey come
on back here that's right that seems
like an oddly specific machine built for
this express purpose I mean obviously
its cargo transporter but we are out of
water
it's are a little less heavy underwater
not everything though apart is that the
siren song of the mermaids
oh hey whoa hey whoa what do you think
you're going now hang on a tick I didn't
know that we were racing my god okay
last hope of humanity let's do this I
guess it's not some chasing after me is
er
oh wait wait a minute
Hey what woo-wee
how do I come I my knots wasn't boy
ain't this some [ __ ] all righty then
what him I still don't trust you
but I guess I trust you more than the
whoa unless you are the whoa probably
are the whoa but I don't know about that
it all comes down to there was something
that made me there was something that
pulled my scan from the data banks and
put me into that suit in the first place
that happened someone or something did
that and they had a reason for doing
that they thought that I force one
reason or another would do something
like that
and there's an opposing force and I
believe that is the whoa because there
are other suits with programs or brain
scans in them that want to attack me so
there are two sides to this I'm not
being duped in that there's there's not
it's it's not all just the whoa I know
that for a fact by process of
elimination or by another process that's
equally valid that there's got to be two
sides to this but I don't know who's
after what I know that the whoa is going
out of control but admittedly
okay cool but admittedly admittedly the
whoa is trying to save humanity it's
just doing it in the wrong way know what
I mean and I guess for some reason it
thinks that this arc isn't the best
option but why would it think that it's
not the best option maybe it thinks that
maybe it needs the scans that are on the
arc maybe all the scans aren't available
everywhere and the arc is like the only
source of all these scans so maybe
that's why the woh wants it but I did
kind of bring the arc right to it I have
no idea I just don't know I just don't
know hello bizarre weird pretty and
wonky
so weird
I gotta admit walking through this game
I haven't even really commented on it
because I've been I've been talking
about this game not so much as a game
but as an experience and his moral
choices in all this philosophy but as
from a game standpoint it is very very
pretty it's a really really cool looking
game it's got a lot of detail in the
environment and admittedly a lot of the
detail does repeat have a tendency to
repeat there is a lot of common themes
throughout it it's all pretty much the
same underwater you know building all
pretty much the same underwater
weird goopy cancerous growth at the same
time it all fits
it's all really pretty to look at like
it was there a grudge over there calm
down there buddy
but I mean just from a technical
standpoint it is a very cool looking
game it really does sound like something
not fun is hanging around here it was
there another way to go around there I
know that's probably the way out over
there but I just want to double check
everything hello you anything important
apparently not okay I'm wasting
everybody's time
all right doesn't sound like voices and
who knows it could be there could be
just human brain scans stuck in every
single wall here there could be hundreds
and thousands of duplicates running
through the whoa.good
but don't tell me tell me what you want
what how enslaved proteins what are you
talking about Suzie
they needed to take it to alpha the
fountainhead of the misery we created
she figured it out
she was going to take
from the Cutlass and eat yourself into a
venomous snake you're saying this toxin
inside of me can kill the Wow altogether
well alright then so I know that voice
sounded familiar because he's one of the
scientists I don't know if his name is
Ross but I have a feeling that's who it
might be but I'm not entirely sure it's
someone who made it back to Omicron to
be able to do all this and I mean
obviously not everyone knew about the
ark project maybe the way that's all the
time that I have for this episode thank
you everybody so much for watching and
as always I will see you in the next
video oh that's alive that was alive Oh
I'm
the biggest big if your thank you my
time